the layoff announcements just keep
coming Disney Amazon Twitter meta
Microsoft Salesforce City Barclays and
lots of others but many of the recent
layoff scrapping headlines are coming
from companies with large revenues and
lots of cash on their balance sheets a
much larger wave of job Cuts may be on
the horizon debt and a looming cash
crunch could be responsible I'll explain
there are more than 900 companies in the
US that haven't produced enough profit
to service their debt for three straight
years according to factset data that
list includes some big names like Boeing
Uber and workday some economists call
these companies zombies and many of them
have a lot of debt but they've been
buoyed in recent years by low interest
rates and a historically elevated stock
market now that debt has become more
expensive and the stock market has
deflated there's a real danger these
companies will need to cut their
workforces and the numbers could be
meaningful these companies have a total
market cap of more than 1.3 trillion
dollars and employ around 1.5 million
people according to factset how did
America's zombie problem get so big well
coming into 2020 lots of companies were
able to stay in business because they
could just keep borrowing money as long
as their valuation stayed high and
interest rates stayed low for the 10
years from 2012 to 2021 the S P 500 saw
an average average total return of 17
percent almost three times its historic
average that boosted the valuations of
public and private companies to Historic
highs and bond yields during that period
were some of the lowest ever recorded
but in 2022 things have changed
drastically
the s p is headed for its worst year
since 2008 and that's making companies
rethink issuing stock or going public
the number of initial public offerings
in October fell by 95 percent from a
year before and with U.S government bond
yield seeing their largest rise in
history corporate bond yields have also
skyrocketed making it way more expensive
for companies to borrow money we're
seeing mergers and Acquisitions and
Venture Capital funding dry up as well M
A activity in the U.S in the last two
months was down by about 43 percent in
the same period last year and Venture
Capital funding for startups was down by
about half in 230 the federal reserve's
policies had kept interest rates low and
pumped money into the economy helping
prop up the zombies but the FED is now
signaling its plans to keep raising U.S
interest rates so corporate borrowing
costs are unlikely to return to their
historic lows anytime soon many of these
companies now have to figure out how to
operate when they can't just go out and
get more money from the market they're
in a cash crunch we could see some
pretty significant layoffs from these
companies as they start running short on
cash and some may turn to bankruptcy or
liquidation that's definitely something
to watch even if the economy starts to
improve it's important to have an
entrepreneurial mindset these days as
rapper little baby reminds us he says
sun up to sun down ain't nothing to do
but get money so forget it I'm working
the block AP cost a cool quarter million
I'm sorry this watch did not come for me
punching the clock that's all for now
see you next time